on est désolé pour ce je dis bah c'est
léger retard parce que c'est quand même
presque une demi-heure mais bon on a
commencé notre précédente audition
également avec du retard donc merci de
d'avoir répondu à présent à notre
habitation donc sur cette commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique et donc nous
sommes très très heureux de pouvoir
échanger avec vous donc avec monsieur
Guillaume Laroque qui est président de
Total énergie marketing France vous avez
fait une carrière de près de 30 ans au
sein du groupe Total énergie dans lequel
vous avez eu des responsabilités dans
plusieurs zones du Monde en Asie en
Afrique en Australie ou encore en
Allemagne et plus récemment vous avez
été directeur du réseau et des cartes
pétrolières et depuis un peu plus de
trois ans vous êtes à la tête de Total
énergie marketing France et directeur de
Total d'énergie marketing pour l'Europe
Monsieur François iOS qui est donc
directeur des certificats d'énergie de
Total énergie vous avez vous aussi fait
une carrière au sein du groupe Total
énergie légèrement plus courte un peu
moins de 20 ans néanmoins vous avez
dirigé la filiale du groupe en charge la
zone Grèce Bulgarie Albanie Chypre Malte
et Caucase ensuite vous avez été
notamment responsable d'une filiale de
Total spécialisée dans les services
premium puis vous avez eu des
responsabilités dans plusieurs régions
en Amérique du Sud aux Antilles ou
encore en Afrique et depuis un peu plus
d'un an et demi vous êtes directeur des
certificats d'économie d'énergie ou vous
couvrez les obligations qui s'imposent à
total à travers les C2
je ne crois pas qu'il soit nécessaire de
présenter votre groupe Total énergie
première entreprise française et acteur
mondial de la production et de la
fourniture d'énergie pétrole et gaz
naturel évidemment mais vous cherchez
dorénavant à vous diversifier
biocarburant énergies renouvelable
électricité et efficacité énergétique et
c'est avec cette variété d'activités que
nous avons voulu vous entendre dans le
cadre de notre commission au delà de
votre rôle historique de pétrolier en
tant que fournisseur d'énergie vous
devez promouvoir l'efficacité
énergétique auprès des consommateurs
d'énergie notamment les particuliers ce
qui implique des économies d'énergie
calculées en kilowattheure cumac
contraction de cumuler et actualisée il
s'agit donc d'inciter vos clients à
effectuer les actions qui contribueront
à réduire la consommation énergétique de
la France cette incitation passe
notamment par les C2E via l'octroi de
prime énergie pour la réalisation de
travaux de rénovation énergétique qui
sont éligibles dispositif comme des
travaux d'isolation ou de nouveaux
équipements de chauffage vous pourrez
d'ailleurs revenir sur l'ensemble des
activités de Total énergie qui sont
liées à la rénovation énergétique des
logements puisque c'est vraiment le cœur
même de notre commission d'enquête
quel regard portez-vous sur les
objectifs et les moyens de la rénovation
énergétique des logements en France
comment à cet égard total énergie en
temps relevé le défi de la massification
et de l'accélération des rénovations de
logement pouvez-vous dresser le bilan de
vos obligations notamment en termes de
C2E ce dispositif qui s'impose aux
fournisseurs d'énergie est-il selon vous
suffisant pour promouvoir l'efficacité
énergétique auprès des consommateurs
d'énergie surtout tels que les
particuliers quelle place
occupe totale énergie dans le
financement des C2E comment les pouvoirs
publics peuvent-ils plus globalement
favoriser la montée en puissance des
rénovations de logement jugez-vous et
dispositifs de soutien à la rénovation
énergétique des logements pertinents et
efficaces et aussi telle n'était pas le
cas ou en tout cas pas suffisamment
quelle évolution
estimez-vous nécessaire voilà déjà un
grand nombre de questions auxquelles je
vais vous laisser le soir alors et à
l'autre de répondre il m'appartiennent
vous dire que cette audition est
diffusant direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat avec un compte
rendu sera bien évidemment publié je
dois également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage de vendre notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure
et bien je vous remercie je vous laisse
la parole et ensuite monsieur le
rapporteur et nos collègues qui
assistent également à l'audition et qui
sont membres de cette commission
d'enquête pourront bien évidemment vous
poser des questions complémentaires
voilà peut-être monsieur le Président de
ton énergie marketing France merci
madame la Présidente et bonjour monsieur
le rapporteur bonjour messieurs les
sénateurs bonjour également merci pour
ce pour ce rappel exhaustif à la fois de
du parcours de Total énergie et des
nôtres personnels
effectivement comme vous l'avez demandé
mentionné dès le début dans votre propos
donc total énergie est devenu une un
acteur majeur de la transition
énergétique en mai 2021 avec une
décision d'ailleurs de changer le nom de
la compagnie qui est devenu total
énergie et l'ambition est également de
figurer parmi les cinq premiers
producteurs mondiaux d'électricité
solaire et renouvelable en 2030 à cet
effet un programme d'investissement de
60 milliards d'ici à 2030 est prévu par
Total énergie qui permettra de
d'atteindre une capacité de production
de 100 GW ce qui fera donc de deux à
l'énergie l'un des cinq grands acteurs
mondiaux de la production d'électricité
renouvelable
c'est aussi le fait de devenir un acteur
majeur de la transition énergétique
l'essor de nouvelles énergies bas
carbone d'autres ordres en particulier
biocarburant le biogaz l'hydrogène les
if you qui est la combinaison donc de
d'hydrogène CO2 c'est aussi pour arriver
au if you l' en particulier la capture
de CO2 d'origine industrielle dans un
premier temps puis d'origine biogénique
afin à la fois de le stocker et de
l'utiliser par exemple dans les fuel
synthétiques tels que
ce faisant le mix de vente le mix de
l'énergie vendue par la compagnie va
changer significativement au cours du
temps en 2030 tout à l'énergie vendra à
peu près 50% de l'énergie qu'elle vendra
sera du gaz naturel 30% des produits
pétroliers les produits pétroliers ont
donc significativement réduit 15 %
d'électricité renouvelable et 5% de
molécules des carbonées qui sont les
fuel et les biocarburants donc je vous
parlais tout à l'heure en 2050 avec
l'objectif au total énergie d'atteindre
la neutralité carbone en Europe y
compris pour la commercialisation des
produits auprès des clients 50% de ses
ventes seront au travers d'une
énigrésité renouvelable 25% par les
molécules décarbonées 25% de pétrole gaz
GNL dans le reste du monde donc on voit
qu'il y a un chiffre significatif une
transition significative du mix de vente
de Total énergie qui ensemble avec la
société accompagne la transformation des
clients dans leur solution énergétique
c'est aussi totale énergie en France je
m'intéresse un peu plus particulièrement
à la France et je prends quelques
exemples pour vous donner une
illustration
une co-entreprise avec ses lentillesse
et Mercedes Benz qui veut faire un
leader de la production de batterie
destinée aux véhicules électriques et
enfin tout à l'énergie en France c'est
aussi un acteur significatif de la
fourniture auprès des entreprises et des
particuliers d'électricité et de gaz
bien sûr comme vous l'avez rappelé en
premier lieu madame la Présidente de
pétrole d'énergie carbonée mais aussi
maintenant d'électricité et de gaz avec
donc 6 millions de clients que Total
énergie A en France alors j'arrive
maintenant après cette introduction
relativement rapide sur
le rôle de Total énergie dans le domaine
des C2E et sur vos questions
donc effectivement la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments joue un rôle
clé dans la trajectoire de réduction des
C2E de la du CO2 émis par la France je
pense que vous connaissez chier bien
mieux que moi et ils ont été encore très
récemment réactualisés en 1990 les
bâtiments représentés 93 millions de
tonnes d'émissions de CO2 64 millions de
tonnes en 2022 45 millions de tonnes en
2030 selon la précédente SNBC et depuis
peu une nouvelle estimation à 30
millions de tonnes donc on voit bien que
le bâtiment va représenter selon nos
estimations 25% de la baisse globale sur
222-2030 du CO2 émis par la France
et oui le dispositif C2E est clé dans la
mise en oeuvre de cette trajectoire
parce que le dispositif C2 est un
dispositif de financement
et que c'est un dispositif de
financement significatif important parce
que la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments passe par deux facteurs qui
nous paraissent clés qui sont
indissociables le premier facteur c'est
la réalisation d'investissement d'où la
nécessité de financement
et qu'il ne faut pas cependant dissocier
d'un facteur d'incitation à un
comportement du consommateur un
comportement vertueux du consommateur
c'est à dire qu'il faut à la fois jouer
sur le paramètre de l'investissement qui
permet de financer la rénovation du
logement mais il ouvre aussi permettre
de jouer sur des incitations
comportementales vis-à-vis du
consommateur
pour entrer déjà un peu plus dans le
détail de votre question totale énergie
donc notre obligation cumulée entre nos
activités
issues de notre commercialisation de
produits carburants ou pétroliers et de
gaz électricité en France représente 101
180 terawatts par an à notre estimation
c'est à peu près 23% d'obligations de la
nation
et en 2023 cela représentait un effort
financier d'environ 1,5 milliards
d'euros
nous avons un rôle très direct dans la
mise en oeuvre des chantiers C2E quand
nous sommes énergéticiens c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait un certain nombre de ces
chantiers de rénovation de logement
concernent des domaines d'activité qui
sont dans le domaine d'activité propre
quand on change une chaudière on est
dans un domaine d'expertise de Total
énergie
pour faire cela on essaie de mettre en
place des mesures qui sont logiques dans
leur cheminement d'abord un on doit
permettre aux clients de mesurer sa
consommation
et il nous paraît important que le
client final ou la personne qui veut
faire un changement de chaudière puisse
mesurer d'abord sa consommation et là je
joue sur le paramètre non pas de
l'investissement mais du comportement
donc nous avons mis en place pour
travers de nos activités gazelek un
suivi mensuel et personnalisé de la
consommation du particulier mais aussi
un comparatif pour
ménage en fonction de sa composition du
nombre de personnes etc par rapport à
ses peines ce qui donne aux particuliers
un repère par rapport à sa consommation
vis-à-vis de la moyenne de ses peines
c'est incitatif et ça permet à ceux qui
sont pas au même niveau que la moyenne
d'essayer d'atteindre cette moyenne
mesurer deuxième point incité et pour
inciter on a mis en place un bonus qui a
atteint en moyenne 90 euros par an par
client pour tous les clients qui avaient
dépassé une réduction de 5% de leur
consommation sur les quatre derniers
mois de l'année 2022 il y a un million
de clients sur les à peu près 6 millions
de clients gaz électricité en France il
y a un million de clients qui ont réussi
à atteindre cet objectif et qui donc ont
réussi à atteindre en moyenne leur bonus
de 90 euros
donc je reviens sur les mots mesurer
inciter dans le inciter je prends un
domaine complètement différent de longue
date comme vous le savez peut-être nous
sommes engagés dans le covoiturage et là
encore on est dans un domaine
d'expertise de Total énergie parce qu'on
est dans le domaine de l'énergie de la
mobilité et dans le covoiturage donc on
est un partenaire de longue date de
blablacar le dispositif avec la placard
est relativement simple tout nouveau
conducteur sur la plateforme blablacar
obtient dès son adhésion nouvelle dans
la plateforme bakbakar un bonus d'entrée
dans la plateforme une incitation et
pour vous donner des chiffres qui vous
donnent des ordres de grandeur nous
avons commencé ce dispositif depuis 2010
c'est 3 millions de nouveaux conducteurs
qui ont obtenu ce bonus parce qu'ils
sont devenus de nouvelles adhérents sur
la plateforme et pour la 2022 elle-même
seule c'est 300 000 nouveaux conducteurs
qui ont été modifiés
ensuite toujours dans notre rôle direct
lié à notre énergéticien nous aidons nos
clients à aller vers une énergie moins
carbonée et là je vous donne des
chiffres précises par exemple le
changement de chaudière dans une année
ça c'est l'année 2022 nous avons
accompagné des projets de 40 000
changements de chaudière qui
principalement sont passés du fioul
domestique soit à des packs soit à des
chaudières pellets
donc alors chaudière chaudière vraiment
parce que poil c'est encore en plus et
le poil est une est un modèle de
d'énergie qui s'additionne
ça c'est notre rôle très direct dans la
mise en oeuvre dc2e on est dans un
domaine de compétence qui nous est
propre et on a un rôle plus au plus
indirect même si nous progression en
compétence parce qu'évidemment on
s'intéresse qu'un masque à ce que l'on
fait qui est notre rôle relatif au fait
que notre statut c'est d'être obligé ces
deux œufs on est principalement
financeurs et ça c'est notre rôle dans
le domaine de l'isolation isolation
comme vous le savez n'est pas un au cœur
de l'expertise de Total énergie
il y a des entreprises bien plus
qualifiées que nous pour mettre en
oeuvre de l'isolation à la fois en titre
de la mise en oeuvre des chantiers et
puis la fabrication des matériaux
nécessaires à réaliser les chantiers
d'isolation pour autant donc selon nos
chiffres on a réalisé 390
000 en 2022
opérations énergétique
en tout de rénovation
194000 était destiné à des publics
précaires et pour vous d'un autre de
grandeur sur ces chiffres là 130 000
isolations étaient relatifs à des
projets d'isolation de combles et de
toiture
et on a fait à peu près 60
000 isolations de murs
non pardon excusez-moi 30 000 isolations
de murs et 25000 isolation de plancher
seulement j'en arrive à un point sur
lequel je sais que vous avez une
attention particulière seulement 5000
innovation globale
par rapport à un nombre de chantiers
annuel qui est quand même très
significatif
et nous savons qu'il y a un objectif de
500 000 alors rénovation complète
performante du gouvernement enfin ou des
autorités qui visent à atteindre le DPEA
ou B
qui n'est pas directement imbriqué
d'ailleurs avec le système des C2E pas
directement mais on voit bien que en
terme de rénovation globale le chiffre
qu'on a réussi à atteindre c'est 5000
alors je me permets du coup de citer sur
quelques points qui viennent en répondre
aux questions que vous nous avez posées
sur comment faire pour accélérer et pour
faire plus
d'abord nous voudrions insister sur le
fait que pour accélérer il faut que le
système qui est quand même assez
complexe le système des C2 est un
système complexe
je ne dis pas qu'il est inutilement
complexe je dis qu'il est de fait
complexe c'est à dire que pour les
entreprises de rénovation de logement
qui sont actives sur le marché
le système des C2E demande un certain
travail
de compréhension du système de telle
manière que l'entreprise qui le met en
oeuvre comprenne un le système des C2 en
soi et de la mécanique du constitution
administrative des dossiers
il est important par le fait de cette
complexité que le système change le
moins souvent possible je pense qu'on
doit pas être les premiers à vous dire
cela je suis désolé si c'est une redite
mais
le système devrait gagner par sa
stabilité en termes de fonctionnement
des fiches elles-mêmes et aussi sa
stabilité en termes de données des
perspectives sur ces objectifs long
terme
ça ne veut pas dire que ce métier long
terme doit forcément être stable et ne
pas changer d'une année sur l'autre mais
anticiper serait une bonne chose
et je vais vous donner un exemple qui
illustre ça et je veux pas que cette
langue soit polémique il est juste
illustratif pour certaines fiches sur
lesquelles nous sommes particulièrement
actifs elles ont parfois changé trois
fois par an
et ça plusieurs conséquences d'abord
avec comme vous pouvez l'imaginer 1,5
milliards d'euros par an de mise en
oeuvre de financement de ces deux e on
s'est équipé d'un point de vue
informatique
on fait pas ça à la main c'est
d'ailleurs pour te rassurant je pense
pour cette commission sauf que quand la
fiche change trois fois par an il faut
trois ajustements nos systèmes
informatiques vous allez dire total
énergie peut arriver à faire ça et c'est
vrai qu'on y arrive avec quelques
efforts mais ça veut dire que les
systèmes de nos partenaires doivent eux
aussi s'adapter à tout cela c'est pas
évident et l'autre élément de changement
d'une fiche au cours d'une année ou
d'une et je ne dis pas que les
motivations politiques au changement de
l'affiche ne sont pas fondés en soi les
fiches ne changent pas par plaisir du
changement de l'affiche elle change pour
des motivations politiques qui bien
souvent quand on lit la raison pour
laquelle la fille change c'est fondé on
comprend mais un changement trop
permanent ou trop régulier entraîne une
incertitude sur la compréhension de la
fiche et immédiatement une augmentation
de votre taux d'inconformité
deuxième point qui nous paraît clé pour
atteindre les objectifs d'accélération
[Musique]
c'est de dire d'emblée qu'il s'agit pas
finalement d'un problème de goulot
d'étranglement financier
les obliger aujourd'hui qui financent le
système des C2E sont des obligés qui ont
suivi au cours des périodes
l'évolution de l'obligation
et l'ont fait d'un point de vue
financier
sans tirer de sonnette d'alarme majeur
par rapport à cette problématique c'est
d'abord et avant tout un goulot
d'étranglement terrain de mise en œuvre
devant lequel nous sommes collectivement
confrontés je dis pas que ce défi du
coup nous échappe ou que nous n'en
n'avons plus pas nous faisons partie de
la solution pour arriver à accélérer
nous faisons partie de l'écosystème qui
contribue à ce que ce soit faisable mais
c'est d'abord avant tout une question de
mise en œuvre et de capacité à faire
et donc pour augmenter cette capacité il
y a deux leviers majeurs qui nous
paraissent immédiatement nécessaires et
que je me permets de d'exposer dès
maintenant c'est la formation
donc il y a un besoin significatif de
formation
des artisans et des professionnels à
deux titres un au titre des compagnons
puisqu'ils vont avoir selon nos
estimations à un besoin de recrutement
de l'ordre de 100000 nouveaux compagnons
pour arriver à accélérer et donc ça veut
dire 100000 personnes à former en plus
formation terrain théorique et terrain
il y a aussi besoin de formation des
entreprises relatives à tout ce qui est
RGE
système de qualification etc ce qui est
tout à fait légitime et donc ce besoin
de formation plusieurs groupes de
travail déjà dans le passé
l'authenticité dont envisager mais
évidemment et but à des questions de
capacité mais il est nécessaire et
indispensable à nos yeux à la capacité à
accélérer et réaliser les travaux le
deuxième univers sur lequel il faut
porter notre attention pour accélérer
aussi en termes de formation c'est
l'univers des bureaux de contrôle
parce que accélérer en termes de mise en
oeuvre des chantiers et des réalisations
de ces deux œufs bien sûr que c'est
c'est un objectif conjoint mais il faut
absolument pour que la chaîne qualité
suive que les bureaux de contrôle
bénéficient eux aussi du recrutement
nécessaire des personnels nécessaires
pour effectuer les contrôles et de la
formation nécessaire à la mise en oeuvre
de ces contrôles
enfin il a encore je crains de dire des
choses que vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu
mais on pense que c'est absolument clé
les chantiers c'est de eux et notamment
les chantiers de rénovation globale que
collectivement nous appelons nos vœux
enfin les pouvoirs publics sont des
chantiers complexes et pour un
particulier ce sont des chantiers qui
sont donc difficiles à suivre et nous
pensons c'est déjà le cas puisqu'il y a
de plus en plus la notion
d'accompagnateur qui mise en place mais
nous pensons qu'il y a un vrai rôle à
jouer et une accélération à mettre en
oeuvre sur le fait que des collectivités
publiques locales de tous ordres que ce
soit des des mairies ou des
collectivités locales ou même des
organismes par un public puisse vraiment
accompagner les particuliers dans une
sorte ce que j'appellerai de maîtrise
d'ouvrage assisté dans la réalisation de
leur chantier donc ils seront pas maître
d'oeuvre le maître d'oeuvre c'est le
bureau d'études ou l'organisme compétent
mais quand vous réalisez des travaux
vous êtes maître d'ouvrage et il y
aurait peut-être un intérêt à ce qu'il y
a une forme d'assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvrage
et et c'est indispensable pensons-nous
pour deux raisons c'est que un quand
vous voulez entreprendre vos travaux au
titre de la rénovation de votre logement
selon notre analyse vous avez deux
motivations principales la première
c'est de réduire votre consommation
énergétique
est-ce qu'on constate c'est
qu'aujourd'hui sur Internet et nous
avons nous-mêmes un site pour cela vous
avez des sites ou des calculatrices qui
vous permettent d'anticiper ce que vos
travaux vont vous permettre de gagner en
termes de réduction du coût de l'énergie
donc vous êtes incité à investir et de
même que vous êtes incité à avoir un
comportement vertueux par contre selon
notre analyse aussi la deuxième raison
principale pour un investisseur
d'investir dans une rénovation
énergétique c'est d'aller améliorer sa
note des PE
et cela n'est pas forcément les experts
les plus qualifiés que vous avez pu
avoir dans cette commission mais cela
nous paraît difficile à anticiper pour
l'investisseur vous êtes un investisseur
vous allez jusqu'à 60 000 euros si on
prend un budget moyen
d'investissement pour une rénovation
globale qui est quand même un montant
significatif même si vous n'avez que 30%
de restes à charge 30% de 60 000 euros
ça reste un investissement significatif
et la motivation d'anticiper votre note
DPE et quand même à nos yeux un facteur
clé dans la décision de l'investissement
et donc peut-être qu'on gagnerait
collectivement à ce que ces
accompagnateurs et je reviens sur mon
dernier point puisse être aussi là pour
conseiller les gens qui entreprendrent
ces investissements dans à la fois
l'anticipation de la réduction de
consommation d'énergie mais aussi
l'anticipation de l'amélioration de la
note des PE
enfin dernier point et je m'arrêterai là
désolé si c'est un peu long comme
introduction
évidemment faut renforcer la
labellisation RGE on est extrêmement
favorable à ce que le RGE prennent plus
de pouvoir encore qu'il n'en a
aujourd'hui alors selon nos estimations
je dis pas que nos chiffres sont
absolument exacts mais on vous donne les
chiffres que sur lesquels nous on
travaille nos hypothèses il y a 63 000
entreprises qui sont R2 aujourd'hui en
France sur les 700 000 à peu près
entreprises du bâtiment et c'est 63000
entreprises RGE emploi environ 800 000
personnes
donc ensuite il y a deux façons de s'y
prendre et là je suis désolé mais nous
ne sommes pas suffisamment qualifiés
pour dire quelle est la meilleure voie
entre les deux c'est soit augmenter le
nombre d'entreprises RGE mais il faut
pas que ça se fasse au détriment de la
qualité
soit aider les entreprises qui sont RGE
à disposer de plus de personnels pour
soutenir leur croissance
ou les deux probablement
dernier point sur lequel je ne voudrais
pas qu'on n'insiste pas beaucoup
d'informations sont aujourd'hui à
disposition des différents acteurs du
secteur notamment les obliger
en termes de notation qualité des
intervenants
et nous pensons d'ailleurs c'est un
effort qu'on doit faire nous-mêmes sans
que les pouvoirs publics nous y incitent
nous pensons qu'il y aurait une
signification valeur ajoutée parce que
cette information puisse circuler de
manière plus fluide
pour vous donner des ordres de grandeur
selon nos estimations il y a environ
100000 contrôles qui sont réalisés
chaque année par les obliger sur les
chantiers qui sont faits c'est quand
même un nombre de contrôles
significatifs sauf que ces contrôles
sont réalisés par différents objets qui
ne partagent pas l'information relative
aux résultats de ces contrôles et qui ne
donne pas non plus forcément une note
qualité je dis bien qualité je dis pas
une note de non-conformité je veux pas
que ce soit punitif mais notre qualité
relative aux intervenants
probablement que des systèmes de partage
d'information plus fluides entre les
intervenants permettrait
de mettre en avant la grande qualité de
la majorité des intervenants qui
interviennent sur ces chantiers
et de donner des paramètres objectifs du
changement de cette grande qualité qui
ne devrait donc pas pâtir parce que ça
deviendra objectif et mesuré des non
qualités qui existent et qui viennent
ternir comme vous le savez l'image
globale potentiellement des chantiers
qui sont réalisés
voilà
ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose à ce stade alors monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président de ces
explications
moi je voulais peut-être revenir sur
déjà un premier point sur vous avez
parlé de l'imbrication là des DPE et C2E
[Musique]
préciser en tout cas qu'est-ce que vous
vous entendez par là c'est vrai que sur
la question du DPE on a vu
la mise en place du nouveau DPE avec
toutes les
critiques en tout cas les les attentes
qui peuvent être derrière ce derrière ce
DPE
mais qui est quand même la base et puis
en plus maintenant opposable donc de les
politiques publiques qui est quand même
un outil assez central et donc sur cette
imbrication justement des C2E sur les
orientations en tout cas les critères
des ligibilité de ces deux e en fonction
des justement du DPE et du changement de
critère de passer de G à a pour le
meilleur
comment enfin voilà comment vous voyez
vous voyez ça c'est vrai qu'on a eu pas
mal de dans les différentes
interventions qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
avoir beaucoup nous disent en fait ça
serait peut-être bien de tout simplifier
en fait et d'aller vers des systèmes de
bouquets et notamment qui permettrait
d'aller plutôt vers
tendre vers de la rénovation plus plus
complète et d'avoir des systèmes en tout
cas à la fois avoir un parcours de
rénovation et puis des systèmes de
bouquets qui permettraient de dire voilà
si j'isole
les murs les combles et je sais pas
changer mes menuiseries enfin qui peut
être un premier bouquet avoir des
systèmes de bouquet comme ça qui
permettraient justement voilà et à
coller justement c'est d'eux savoir si
c'est quelque chose auquel vous avez pu
réfléchir en termes de peut-être de
simplification
ensuite sur pareil entre ces deux œufs
et ma prime rénove c'est vrai qu'on peut
avoir des orientations enfin qui sont
deux dispositifs pour le coup très
différent
mais souvent avec des orientations aussi
qui peuvent être parfois un petit peu
contradictoires quoi entre ce qu'on peut
aller chercher je sais pas quand il y a
eu des combles à 1 euro
sur prime rénov on va plutôt essayer
d'aller sur de la rénovation globale
enfin voilà donc du coup on peut avoir
comme ça des choses un peu
contradictoires et puis surtout un
problème de lisibilité puisque les
personnes qui font appel
ont un peu du mal à comprendre déjà que
ces deux dispositifs différents enfin
voilà de et donc de c'est ce que vous
avez déjà réfléchi à comment rendre en
fait plus le plus compatible en fait
c'est de ces deux aides et peut-être
plus simple leur application
sur sur le RGE bon vous avez vous en
avez parlé en fait sur la question à la
fois bon ma formation des entreprises et
puis la question plutôt justement de
monter en puissance sur le RGE c'est
vrai qu'on a eu pas mal de retour et de
et de questions sur le contrôle des
sur le chantier en fait et de contrôler
réel et c'est vrai que le fait que on
part sur une question du d'une
entreprise qui est labellisée donc qui a
fortiori fait des travaux qui sont qui
sont corrects on se pose la question de
savoir s'il faudrait pas faire peut-être
un peu l'inverse je sais pas si c'est
l'inverse mais en tout cas de se dire
qu'il vaut mieux avoir un contrôle sur
sur site et un contrôle sur sur le
chantier
quitte à permettre à des entreprises qui
n'est pas le RGE de pouvoir de pouvoir
réaliser des travaux à condition
justement qui soit qui soit validées en
fin de en fin de chantier et donc il y a
pas mal de pas mal d'entreprises et puis
de l'audition qu'on a pu faire où on
nous a
évoquer la question du consuel enfin sur
un système du consuel pour l'électricité
ou en fait notre entreprise électricité
qui va intervenir sur un sur un chantier
actuellement c'est une obligation à la
consuel et la sous contrôle sur chantier
à chaque fois et donc se dire est-ce
qu'il pourrait pas y avoir quelque chose
similaire en tout cas qui permettrait
justement d'améliorer justement cette
qualité et peut-être de monter en
compétences et les entreprises donc
votre votre avis aussi sur cette sur cet
aspect là et puis peut-être pour
terminer sur la question du du confort
d'été puisque c'est vrai que c'est un
élément aussi qui est
mine de rien dans le dispositif très peu
abordé le DPE la borne très peu les
aides en tout cas sur même des
dispositifs en fait sur sur le confort
d'été que ce soit des casquettes
solaires que ce soit des stores etc sont
pas forcément pris en compte mais aussi
sur l'intervention et l'utilisation de
certains matériaux dont on sait qu'ils
auront un impact sur le confort d'été et
donc voilà sur savoir si c'est quelque
chose sur une démarche en tout cas que
vous intégrez dans vos dans vos
réflexions et puis vous terminez là je
suis allé voir votre site c'est
l'énergie tout compris
non mais c'est vrai du coup c'est
intéressant parce que c'est d'aller voir
en fait tous les sites on avait un J
juste avant vous en fait c'est des sites
qui sont fait à peu près sur le même le
même calibrage et c'est vrai que quand
on va sur le site en fait la première
des choses c'est en gros combien je vais
avoir de prime enfin c'est quand même un
peu ça et donc derrière
voilà qu'est-ce que je peux faire et en
fait oriente quand même plutôt sur du
monogest
soit chaudière soit isolation mais qui
sont quand même plutôt orientés
là-dessus puisque j'ai encore vu sur
aucun site en fait une réorientation
justement sur par exemple un
accompagnateur rénov pour se dire faites
déjà peut-être une autie une Audi ou une
étude et ensuite vous pourrez vous
lancer dans une démarche voilà et donc
du coup ça me permet de vous poser la
question justement de mon accompagnateur
Renov comment comment vous le vous le
voyez et comment comment vous percevez
en tout cas cette mise en place de mon
accompagnateur rénov dans ce processus
en tout cas de rénovation et
d'accompagnement des des personnes dans
la rénovation
merci Monsieur alors sur le premier
point relais
à l'imbrication entre donc ces deux œufs
DPE rénovation globale moi je vais
essayer de donner quelques chiffres qui
sont les chiffres avec lesquels on
travaille je dis pas qu'ils sont
forcément absolument exacts notre notre
idée c'est qu'un forfait rénovation
global c'est à peu près 60 000 euros
et que le cumul des monogestes va vous
amener à peu près 65 un peu plus parce
qu'en fait soit vous faites une relation
globale vous avez peut-être un peu
économisé sur le chantier global mais
pas de manière extrêmement significative
ensuite notre notre
[Musique]
calcul du reste à charge et de 30% je
parle des foyers précaires
30% pour les foyers précaires
et si on regarde quel est le reste à
charge en faisant chaque geste
individuellement on arrive plutôt à
quelque chose de l'ordre de 40%
. donc à peu près 10 % de plus donc vous
avez un écart de 6000 entre 6 et 10000
euros entre le fait de faire une
rénovation globale et le fait de faire
une rénovation par geste
c'est donc un chiffre qui relativement
significatif et qui est en toute
objectivité pour un calcul économique
devrait inciter en soi à la réalisation
de la rénovation globale
sans être des experts du sujet on
constate chez nos clients plusieurs
points de départ différents déjà c'est à
dire qu'il y a ceux qui ont déjà les
doubles vitrages ils ont pas le reste
enfin je vous donne je vous dis des
choses que vous avez déjà entendu ce
pour qui finalement il faut se
concentrer sur la laine de verre dans
les combles parce que c'est là qu'il y a
vraiment un sujet pour eux en fonction
de l'étage auquel ils habitent etc donc
là je vous donne rien de de bien
significatif
je vais venir sur ma problématique de
stabilité pour répondre à votre question
en termes de reste à charge pour les
précaires par le passé on a eu certains
gestes qui n'avaient plus qu'un coup de
1 euro reste à charge
collectivement j'aurais tendance à dire
on s'est dit un euro c'est très bien du
point de vue du financement
c'est pas aussi bien du point de vue de
l'implication de la personne chez qui
les travaux sont réalisés pour s'assurer
du fait qu'il soit bien fait et qu'il
soit faible fait et bien fait
c'est-à-dire qu'en gros le raisonnement
était de dire le 1 euro
des risques de ne pas suffisamment
impliquer la personne chez qui les
travaux sont réalisés dans l'exécution
parfaite des travaux qui sont réalisés
chez elle et vaudra donc mieux qu'il y
ait un reste à charge puisque ça permet
aux gens d'être plus sensibilisés sur la
qualité et la réalisation faut-il que ce
reste à charge soit de l'ordre de 30%
en partant de 1 euro sur un montant
global de 60000 euros je dis pas que
c'est à nous forcément de fixer ces
paramètres parce que c'est vraiment des
paramètres qui sont fixés plutôt du côté
des autorités mais il y a probablement
de prendre une problématique
d'élasticité entre le reste à charge et
le nombre de travaux réalisés forcément
et par conséquent quand vous regardez
par contre chaque geste individuellement
finalement le geste individuellement est
moins effrayant entre guillemets en
termes de nécessité de financement et
même si vous avez un prêt à taux zéro
comme les précaires sont les des
premiers et deuxième défi de fiscaux et
qu'on a une estimation d'un revenu de
l'ordre de 10 à environ 10000 euros par
an quand vous avez 6000 euros de
restacharge même avec un prêt à taux
zéro ça quand même toujours un niveau
d'investissement significatif qui vous
reste à financer ça le premier point le
deuxième point c'est allez vous trouver
une entreprise capable de tout faire
et ce qui est une disent nos équipes du
terrain ceux qui sont en charge de
produire les dossiers de C2E c'est que
malheureusement
le nombre d'entreprises capables de
faire une rénovation globale n'est pas
égale à la somme des entreprises
capables de faire des monogestes
et donc ne serait-ce que d'un point de
vue de la capacité physique à réaliser
ces chantiers on n'a pas le même point
de départ de capacité
donc on arrive à une problématique de
formation je reviens là-dessus la
rénovation énergétique globale est un
geste complexe qui nécessite de la
formation
ensuite et là j'arrive à votre dernière
question sur comment faire pour
accompagner à la fois au titre des sites
qui donnent des des indications aux
clients sur et vous avez dit l'énergie
tout compris effectivement est très
centrée aujourd'hui sur une calculatrice
qui permet d'anticiper aux particuliers
à quoi il a le droit en terme d'aide ce
qui est un peu l'objectif ici et comment
essayer de les inciter et de les fléchir
entre guillemets vers la rénovation
globale je reviens sur les deux points
qui me paraissent essentiels c'est un
une capacité à anticiper au travers de
ces sites une réduction de la
consommation énergétique et ça on se
sent capable de le faire par contre ce
que on ne se sent pas capable de faire
aujourd'hui nous-mêmes dans ce type de
site c'est de renseigner sur la note DPE
que ce type de travaux vous permettra
d'aller chercher et c'est quand même un
point essentiel de votre décision
d'investissement si vous allez investir
60000 euros sur votre logement en
moyenne je dis pas que tous les
logements c'est 60 000 et que même avec
30% de reste à charge et d'ailleurs
c'est quand même 60% du pour les
modestes c'est plus 30% c'est 60% c'est
des montants qui sont significatifs qui
demandent je pense à pouvoir anticiper
et donc pour entrer dans votre débat sur
qu'est-ce que vous préconiseriez je vois
plus de valeur à ce que les gens
puissent anticiper
ce que leur décision va créer
que d'avoir une forme de simplification
du parcours
je sais bien que le parcours est
complexe je sais bien qu'il y a et je
reviens sur votre question sur les
tâchement entre ma prime rénove laisser
deux œufs c'est pas tout à fait pareil
la définition des modestes n'est pas la
même entre l'un et l'autre
les pourcentages de restes à charge sont
pas les mêmes non plus d'accord est-ce
que collectivement on va arriver à
aligner parfaitement tous ces systèmes
et est-ce qu'on se fixe comme objectif
d'aligner tous les systèmes de
financement ou d'incitation pour qu'il
soit tous les mêmes ça me paraît être un
objectif difficile à atteindre par
contre je trouve qu'on devrait avoir
comme objectif le fait que
l'investisseur quel qu'il soit puisse
anticiper le bienfait de son
investissement pour lui-même
et donc à la fois les sites dont vous
parlez mais même pour nous il est
difficile dans nos propres calculatrices
d'anticipation de réaliser des
calculatrices d'anticipation de la note
DPE ce serait complexe et d'où je
reviens et c'est le deuxième question
que vous avez posé sur rapporteur sur le
rôle
de ce que alors de ce qui est appelé je
veux pas me tromper dans les termes pour
qu'on se comprenne bien de ce qui est
appelé donc les les accompagnateurs pour
nous c'est clé parce que c'est complexe
il faut un accompagnateur parce que ce
sont des chantiers pour tous ceux qui
ont révisé des chantiers de rénovation
dans leur propre logement vous avez bien
vu on a bien vu que c'est pas ce ne sont
pas des chantiers faciles
et dernier point sur
votre problématique de qualité
alors
là je vais laisser François vous donner
quelques éléments plus détaillés mais à
l'issue de chaque chantier nous appelons
les clients
de chaque chantier vous faisons des
contrats téléphoniques et je te laisse
éclairer un peu le résultat des contrats
effectivement on appelle tous les
clients mais on arrive à enjoindre un
peu plus de 50%
et ses clients nous disent dans la très
grande majorité qui sont pleinement
satisfaits de leur de leurs travaux on a
à peu près 2% qui demandent des services
après vente mais les bénéficiaires n'ont
pas forcément la vision technique de la
conformité du chantier d'où l'intérêt
des contrôles physiques qui sont faits
aussi en nombre sur les C2E à peu près
100 000 au niveau de la nation donc à
peu près un quart à notre niveau ce
qu'on peut dire et là on va toucher un
petit peu à la question de de
l'articulation en fait des différents
dispositifs et des différents contrôles
c'est que il y a des contrôles au niveau
du RGE il y a des contrôles au niveau du
dispositif ma prime rénovation il y a
des contrôles au niveau des C2E et tous
ces univers là
de contrôle ne se parlent pas
et donc
même si effectivement le contrôle est
vertueux
il pourrait être fait de façon peut-être
un peu plus efficiente par une meilleure
fluidité
entre les entre les acteurs
et donc pour passer à un système type
consuel qui serait idéal enfin
effectivement idéalement et on doit
rédurer considérablement le
problématique des non-conformités à
l'issue de chaque chantier un contrôle
réalisé par un technicien compétent
sauf que aujourd'hui
nous dit-on sur la capacité à trouver
des bureaux de contrôle disponibles
donc on va pas buter sur un problème de
fin de process ou de vision des choses
on est aligné là-dessus il faut qu'on
revienne sur la réalité de la capacité à
faire s'il n'y a que 100 000 contrôles
par an aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait il
est très difficile déjà pour nous
aujourd'hui en tant que producteur de
C2E de mobiliser les bureaux de contrôle
nécessaires à la réalisation des
contrôles déjà qu'on doit faire même si
on essaie de faire en plus d'où l'idée
dans un premier temps c'est une idée un
premier pas pragmatique qu'il est
peut-être pas aussi ambitieux qu'un
consuel mais qui a un premier pas
pragmatique et un premier objectif
humble mais qui a donc peut-être plus de
chances de d'être atteint qui est de
travailler sur la mise en commun de ces
données
dernier point de votre question monsieur
rapporteur sur le confort d'été je me
permettrai de vous demander qu'on puisse
vous revenir par écrit sur le sujet je
m'avoue moi
compétence sur le sujet désolé
[Musique]
est-il d'autres questions non oui
Laurent Burgoa merci Madame la présente
monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure que vous intervenez
d'isolation de d'immeubles vétuste
est-ce que vous êtes déjà intervenus
dans des quartiers rénovation urbaine
est-ce que vous avez des partenariats
avec des structures comme la rue ou Lana
ça m'intéresserait puis ça vous
donnerait une image sociale d'un grand
groupe français
dans la région en fait il y a beaucoup
de projets notamment
à l'énergie renouvelable comme projet
dans mon département du Gard en
photovoltaïque
mais est-ce que justement vous envisagez
tel partenariat pour donner une image
encore plus positive que ce que vous
avez
je vais laisser François iOS répond plus
en détail on a déjà fait des
partenariats avec Lana dans le passé
et la rue mais plus particulièrement
avec la nappe pour ce qui me concerne
par rapport à la rénovation urbaine dans
les quartiers et l'avantage de ces
partenariats mais je te laisserai les
plus souvent c'est la capacité à faire à
plus grande échelle
c'est-à-dire à faire des projets de
réalisation plus globaux
ce qui
pour notre objectif commun d'atteindre
de rénovation à une vertu c'est
qu'effectivement on arrive à mobiliser
des chantiers significatifs des
intervenants sur lesquels la peau pour
le coup la mise en place des contrôles
est peut-être plus aisée
et à une plus grande échelle je te
laisse aller plutôt le détail
ce qu'on peut dire effectivement c'est
qu'on a beaucoup de bailleurs sociaux
avec lesquels nous travaillons sur
toutes les géographies de la France
métropolitaine voilà et s'il devait y
avoir des meilleures sociaux qui ont
envie de travailler avec nous on sera
très heureux de pouvoir les accompagner
mais c'est effectivement
j'irai un des des gisements de
certificats d'économie d'énergie qui
nous paraissent tout à fait important à
privilégier et d'ailleurs le
le fait qu'une partie de l'obligation
soit fléchés vers les publics précaires
nous invite également à aller vers ces
bailleurs sociaux ce qui nous semble
tout à fait vertueux et sain autre point
et c'est pour confirmer notre intérêt à
ses partenariats qui ont cours enfin ces
des partenaires qu'on connaît très bien
c'est que souvent dans les projets qu'on
mène avec par exemple Lana les deux
volets à la fois d'investissement mais
aussi d'incitation de comportement
vertueux sont traités
ce qui nous paraît de nouveau je
reprends mon point de départ
indissociable c'est à dire que il ne
faudrait pas qu'une rénovation
énergétique
refasse réduire la vigilance du ménage
sur sa consommation
je dis pas que c'est forcément ce qu'on
constate dans nos chiffres parce qu'on
n'a pas tous les deux mais je dis juste
il faut absolument arriver à accompagner
les deux volets pour réussir
et donc effectivement en général avec
Lana on arrive à traiter plusieurs de
ces points les programmes aussi jouent
un rôle d'ailleurs
alors vous avez dit combien
l'accompagnement était absolument
nécessaire et fondamental
sur le dispositif mon accompagnateur
rénove
quels
dispositif engie que l'on a auditionné
avant vous
déplorer peut-être ne pas avoir été
suffisamment associée via une assistance
à maîtrise d'ouvrage parle mon
accompagnateur Renov puisque de fait les
obliger de ces deux œufs en sont exclus
est-ce que pour vous c'est quelque chose
que
voilà que vous regrettez et qu'elle peut
être la bonne étendue de
l'accompagnement lors d'une façon
générale et ça juste rémunération parce
qu'on a souvent eu des approches très
différentes de ce que de la bonne
rémunération d'un accompagnement des
chiffres qui étaient très très éloignés
des uns des autres
de 150 à 200 euros voire à des sommes
beaucoup plus importantes et une moyenne
on nous a dit c'est plutôt de l'ordre de
1500 à 2000 euros de mémoire excusez-moi
si c'est pas tout à fait exact
il y a eu des programmes sur ce sujet
donc en fait on a été quand même quelque
part impliqué parce que s'il y a des
programmes qui ont été mis en œuvre pour
réaliser une forme d'accompagnement pas
forcément au travers d'un dispositif
type accompagnateur Renov il y a eu des
programmes dans le passé qui visaient
effectivement à aider les particuliers à
avoir une meilleure assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrage
donc c'est une façon de financer ce
dispositif premier point puisque ça a
déjà eu lieu
au fond le pré politique du financement
elle est pas plus c'est pas le goulot
d'étranglement que nous n'y sommes que
nous n'y soyons pas associés directement
ça me paraît pas en soi un problème je
veux pas me décider de mes je vois même
que une certaine vertu au fait que
l'accompagnateur rénove intervienne
indépendamment et donc il est là pour
aider le ménage à prendre des décisions
de deux ordres comme je vous disais à
mon sens c'est des décisions relatives à
l'économie d'énergie donc il faut bien
que ce soit quelque part indépendant du
vendeur d'énergie qu'on a rien contre le
fait que effectivement ce soit
indépendant c'est pas interdit que
l'accompagnateur Vienne consulter les
sites des vendeurs d'énergie pour se
faire une idée lui-même mais si
quelqu'un qui aura consulté plusieurs
sites aura constitué un savoir qui lui
est propre il sera plus pertinent pour
donner un conseil indépendant et le
deuxième élément pour moi de
l'accompagnateur Renov c'est de donner
une anticipation de la note DPE donc ils
sont indépendant des acteurs du marché
ne me choque pas
et finalement la problématique ça va
être de nouveau une problématique de
capacité c'est-à-dire
et de faire connaître parce que il y a
deux il y a peut-être suffisamment
insisté là-dessus dans les propos qu'on
a produit auprès de vous mais il y a à
la fois un problème de capacité à
réaliser mais aussi un problème de
formation et de faire connaître
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a encore beaucoup
de gens finalement qui ne savent pas ce
que c'est que ces deux œufs même si
c'est des montants considérables comme
ces missions investies dans les nations
en termes de C2E et et un guichet qui
permet on a vu des guides
il y a des guides qui sont d'ailleurs
très bien faits qui sont faits on a un
guide là il fait 45 pages
qui est un guide qui vous donne
justement j'ai quoi j'ai le droit en
termes de prime rénov quel est mon droit
en terme de ces deux œufs etc etc etc on
voit bien que la nécessité de produire
des guides de 45 pages et c'est pas une
critique que je fais là c'est parce que
le système est complexe je dis pas qu'il
est inutilement complexe il l'est
demande une accompagnement
et donc je pense pas que ce soit un
mauvais investissement parce que je
pense que cet investissement dans
l'accompagnement augmentera l'efficacité
des travaux et infinie nous fera
collectivement
pas forcément réduire l'intensité
d'investissement qu'on veut produire
dans la rénovation énergétique c'est pas
ça que je veux dire mais en tout cas ça
rendra les chantiers beaucoup plus
efficace ça c'est sûr et je pense que
les particuliers qui seront accompagnés
par quelqu'un qui est indépendant dans
son conseil seront rassurés soit en
confiance et parti et auront plus
d'incitation à investir
autre point tout à l'heure que j'ai pas
traité et excusez moi si j'ai peut-être
oublié un point de question de monsieur
le rapporteur et j'y pense maintenant
mais le Président si vous le permettez
d'y revenir
moi je ne sais pas dire pourquoi c'est
mieux de faire une rénovation globale
tout de suite plutôt que de laisser les
gens faire des rénovations monogestes à
partir du moment où elles sont bien
faites bien sûr qu'une rénovation
globale permet d'atteindre immédiatement
un objectif efficacité énergétique
supérieure incontestable mais les
ménages ont des capacités de financement
différentes au cours de leur vie des
capacités de des envies de réalisation
des travaux différents en fonction du
caractère invasif des travaux dans leur
propre logement on voit bien que les
bailleurs
les bailleurs ont des comportements
assez logiques on voit beaucoup de
chantiers de rénovation globale sont
initiés par des bailleurs des
propriétaires dans le but est de mettre
en location de logement je pense que ça
tient en fait que eux ils ont avec
pastille financé et deux ils ont
probablement des phases entre les
locataires qui leur permettent justement
de réaliser des travaux plus invasifs
mais si vous êtes
occupant de votre propre logement
pourquoi faudrait-il considérer que
c'est nécessairement uniquement une
rénovation globale qui est vertueuse je
j'ai pas la compétence personnelle je ne
sais pas si tu veux élaborer là-dessus
mais je ne vois pas en quoi les
monogestes sont en soi pas forcément
souhaitables s'ils sont bien faits oui
et à partir du moment où on s'inscrit
dans un parcours et on pourrait avoir un
parcours et quelque part et vous le dis
et vous-même monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente quand même la note
DPE est un aiguillon significatif global
aujourd'hui utilisé en France et qui
paraît tout à fait pertinent il faut
juste je pense que les gens puissent
savoir qu'est-ce que mon investissement
produit de bien au titre de ma note DPE
oui j'ai couplé très juste effectivement
en disant dans le même sens que
Guillaume on a une grande diversité de
situations individuelles de logement de
disponibilités financière pour engager
des travaux et je pense que à un moment
où on veut accélérer il faut plutôt
ouvrir des portes confirmées c'est à
dire que des personnes qui sont plus à
l'aise avec une des rénovations par
étape qui va commencer d'abord par
l'enveloppe puis par la chaudière puis
par autre chose je pense qu'il faut il
faut laisser
gérer les les particuliers avoir ce
choix là en revanche il faut que ce
choix il soit éclairé il faut qu'il soit
éclairé par l'accompagnateur Renov mais
il faut aussi qu'il soit éclairé par
l'artisan et je me permettrai juste
d'appuyer là-dessus l'artisan
c'est un homme en qui ou une femme en
qui le particulier va accorder sa
confiance et va il va demander des
conseils à son artisan
sur la conduite opportunes ou pas de
chantier de rénovation
et là j'irai tous les programmes
d'ailleurs on en finance certains qui
ont permettre de former des
responsables d'accompagnement à la
rénovation de ces artisans de paraissent
absolument fondamental parce que je
pense que une bonne rénovation
passera souvent aussi par un artisan qui
dispense les les bons conseils
lui égarent à des situations
individuelles bien particulières
une remarque par rapport à ça sur la
formation des artisans je pense là
dessus il y a pas de il y a pas de débat
après c'est vrai que s'il change ma
chaudière que j'ai du coup un plombier
chauffagiste qui va venir quoi qu'il en
soit il va peut-être très bien me
conseiller sur sur quel type de
chaudière sur quel type enfin voilà vers
quoi aller mais il me conseillera pas
sur par quoi faut que je commence et ce
qu'il faut plutôt que je mette je change
mes menuiserie bon mon isolation par
l'extérieur etc mais comment quoi donc
il y a de toute façon besoin d'avoir
cette vision globale et donc du coup ce
parcours quoi et qui peut être
effectivement accompagnateur rénov mais
en tout cas
en revanche il pourra vous conseiller
sur les dispositifs d'aide qui pourront
à moins de rire le reste à charge du
particulier
pour revenir par rapport à ce que vous
disiez au début c'est que du coup vous
êtes producteur d'énergie enfin premier
et donc du coup sur le mix énergétique
nous annonciers du coup de passer plutôt
sur une bascule aller plutôt vers 50 %
de l'énergie renouvelable par rapport
justement à toute la réflexion qui peut
y avoir actuellement
par beaucoup justement de chaudière
changement d'équipement d'équipements de
chauffage on est après avoir été du
fioulau gaz maintenant on est plutôt sur
de la pompe à chaleur et donc plutôt sur
l'électricité et avec c'est vrai un
tentation peut-être en tout cas mais de
dire qu'on peut décarboner en passant on
va dire 100% en électricité ce qui
permettrait de décarboner complètement
la question du du chauffage
ce qui ne résout pas tout on le sait
mais du coup quel est votre approche
vous par rapport à ça puisque en fait en
étant à la fois producteur d'énergie
est quasi de toutes les énergies pas
toutes mais d'une grande partie
quelle est votre approche sur justement
les orientations et comment vous voyez
justement cette
enfin voilà les orientations qu'on peut
donner sur le type d'énergie en fonction
de du type de bâtiment et du chauffage
donc déjà c'est d'accompagner justement
ces orientations pour être tout à fait
clair
un on essaye de les de les anticiper et
de les de les comprendre on a vu des
annonces de l'Union européenne qui
annoncent 10 millions de packs d'ici
on a fait quelques calculs de cointal je
dis pas qu'ils sont forcément très
justes mais c'est des hypothèses de
travail la France c'est à peu près 10%
de la consommation énergétique de
l'Union européenne donc si la France
c'est 10% des packs ça fait un million
de packs en France
vous avez aujourd'hui en France selon
nos estimations 11 millions de chaudière
que ce soit des chaudières pack il y en
a à peu près déjà 5 4 à 5 millions en
France que ce soit des chaudières fuel
domestiques il y en a 3 millions et donc
le reste et les autres énergies
en 2022 en France il y a à peu près 650
000 packs nouvelles qui ont été vendus
donc si vous voulez un taux de
croissance de d'un million de packs
supplémentaires nous paraît presque dans
le dans le mouvement actuel et donc on
accompagne ce mouvement en fait les
décisions des particuliers sont vraiment
basées sur ce concilier c'est les
particuliers ils prennent ces décisions
là accompagnées par les chauffagistes on
accompagne et donc j'essaie de traduire
les objectifs européens et là encore
vous avez vu que c'était des calculs
stimatifs je sais pas comment exactement
cet objectif de 10 millions de réel sera
traduit dans les faits en France mais on
voit bien qu'on est sur des phénomènes
qui sont presque des phénomènes connus
et qui sont en place
qui permettent effectivement à ce que je
voulais dire au départ par exemple nous
on avait on a quand même réussi à
changer 40000 chaudière du fioul à la
PAC et au pellet
donc on anticipe on accompagne on
observe le mouvement du marché les
mouvements du marché actuel il est très
fort mais très fortement poussé par la
décision des particuliers au fond je
pense que le driver majeur enfin le
driver par avance un investissement le
le sous-jacent majeur de la décision des
particuliers pour avoir 650 000 packs de
plus l'année dernière en France c'est
des décisions individuelles qu'ils ont
pris par rapport à l'anticipation à eux
qu'ils ont du coût de l'énergie et de
l'énergie qui veulent faire le choix
pour dont ils veulent faire le choix
pour leur logement donc nous allons
accompagner ces mouvements qui sont des
mouvements de fond du marché il y a des
ambitions politiques qui sont exprimées
qui permet de donner une impulsion puis
ensuite le principal acteur du
changement c'est bien le client et c'est
ensemble avec la société comme on le dit
dans nos propres objectifs que nous
allons réaliser la transition
énergétique
et
sur le choix du client évidemment mais
c'est sûr que quand on va financer une
Pâque on va orienter sur une plaque quoi
et pas sur une chaudière gaz ou pareil
quand on interdit se dire fioul ben
c'est fini et donc on passe sur autre
chose l'orientation elle est quand même
fixée effectivement par les décisions
des décisions politiques mais c'est vrai
qu'on a eu tout à l'heure avec avec
engie cette discussion là sur le fait
que il peut y avoir aussi une réflexion
aussi peut-être plus locale en fait et
sur les types d'énergie par exemple
quelqu'un qui va mettre une PAC alors
que juste à côté d'un réseau de chaleur
c'est peut-être pas forcément le plus
pertinent quand on a un réseau de gaz et
que on a de la méthanisation bah on peut
peut-être se dire que ici au contraire
le gaz est peut-être intéressant plutôt
que plutôt que d'électricité enfin bon
voilà du coup il y a aussi peut-être
cette ces orientations là effectivement
il y a le marché mais il y a aussi
comment on raisonne en fonction aussi de
la production aussi plus locale
je comprends tout à fait effectivement
enfin il y a des gens qui ont des
contraintes il y aura des contraintes
dans le système
ceci étant dit je pense que le
particulier éclairé et là pour le coup
dans la dans la problématique de la
consommation d'énergie il y a quand même
beaucoup de manières de s'éclairer pour
faire une décision prendre des décisions
éclairées éclairées par lui-même au
travers des antispations qu'ils veulent
faire et que les par son chauffagiste
qui lui aussi l'aide à prendre ses
décisions et effectivement dans le cadre
des contraintes qui sont définies par
les pouvoirs publics mais qui pourront
pas résoudre avec une loi nationale ou
européenne des problématiques de réseaux
de chaleur locaux c'est évidemment c'est
donc qu'on est des cadres globaux
j'imagine que c'est pas possible de
faire autrement et je pense même que
c'est une bonne chose qui est une
impulsion politique
et qu'ensuite les acteurs locaux parce
qu'ils ont les moyens de prendre des
décisions éclairées arrivent à adapter
leur décision en fonction des
opportunités locales ça me paraît tout à
fait souhaitable et je pense que c'est
le cas je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
cas
et bien merci beaucoup messieurs pour
ces échanges on vous souhaite une bonne
fin de journée au revoir